a company called top tail they do games  for kids for mobile devices like iOS or  Android they want to relieve new game  every two weeks so if you look from the  technology part of of that equation this  is something really really challenging  with Google cloud platform and Google  App Engine specifically it actually  means that they can deploy new versions  of the back-end they can support more  games and that wasn't be possible  without something like Google App Engine  we have that unique methodology of we  call that transformation in 21 days and  actually that means that we take the  customer from where they are and move  them to Google+ cloud platform and  providing them with some real results in  just three weeks  you